pa je suis fatigué c'est tellement dur
d'être youtuber et d'avoir une chaise
cassée
si seulement je pouvais me détendre
qu'on me masse comme ça pour détendre
tous ses muscles si gros et ses
imposants et babeth personnes massées je
m'en bats les couilles j'ai trouvé une
alternative
mr manager c'est un jeu ghetto c'est un
jeu ghetto que les choses soient claires
entre nous c'est un jeu ghetto mais en
gros on va rencontrer des filles on va
parler avec quelqu'un faire connaissance
et si on leur plaît elles vont ou passé
hier un érotiques ou sexuelles de calmer
bouilhonnac les gars ils vont me masser
à l'aide d'un ustensile appelé manette
de jeu vidéo je suis curieux de voir si
ça marche
j'ai besoin de me détendre me jugez pas
un regret qui se détendant on veut juger
pas à un petit tuto alors première étape
poser vaillamment hockey une fois qu'on
a posés par également promettre contrô
ler on le met sur notre nuque et ensuite
on laisse place à la personne qui doit
ok bon bref ouais bon gros c'est un
message pour mais qu'un patron d'amico
amoureux qui n'est ce pas je prends pas
le bon est jaune et c'est ton vieux pote
olivier essayé je sais que tu aimes les
massages n'est ce pas
regard cette application qui s'appelle
lynge heures c'est ainsi de rencontre où
des gens vont passer bon jeu simplifié
mais pourquoi voulait toujours trouver
une histoire dans les jeux vidéo
d'effroyables il juste pas d'histoire
font voulait pas créer d'histoires
autour du massage ok c'est parti on est
sûr lingers mon profil ça c'est mon
profil et ça c'est moi dorothy 15
étoiles et j'ai zéro étoile amer mais
j'peux pas du coup j'ai zéro étoile je
fais comment ah bah je peux avoir que l
ok bon ok ça marche oh oui elle avait là
et qui mon profil demandé la permission
scanner mon corps en 3d quand même ok
donc on s'est donné rendez vous dans un
restaurant coucou mon nom et royal mais
tout le monde m'appelle tuto tuto quoi
tu te botter tuto au fond des choses à
chaud je vais observer de dehors depuis
un moment donc tu étais en train de me
matter de l'autre côté de la fenêtre
ouais c'est bien ça ouais c'est pas bien
pas du tout moi aussi jeune fille
souffre au tu es exactement comme moi oh
mon dieu
la bête a vibré un ado staff ou là et
c'était comme moi je pense que devrait
jouer à un jeu rigolo par exemple que tu
me masse et qu'en retour je ne te masse
pas quel est ton habitude la plus
bizarre
j'aime faire pipi dans la douche j'adore
prétendent que je suis un chat et
regarder les gens très relais les
fenêtres je veux pas jouer ce jeu jamais
encore plus dans la douche fait pas ce
genre savoir que maintenant ça va lui
poser une question et je vais lui poser
la question suivante
aimes-tu les massages ah je pensais pas
qu'elle me demander ça c'est parti comme
ça c'est parti
[Musique]
wa el mas bien elle marche très très
bien
squeeze en 2017 quand même on en est là
est ce que cette position est
confortable
franchement nos attentes en train de
baiser le coup ça doit s'appuyer sur un
truc où il faut pas le taux qui
attendait depuis un point vital et de me
couper le sens je vais mourir ok je fais
quoi ensuite c'est une masse combien de
temps faites et ce qu'elles vont tout de
masse et de la même manière on passe à
la question trop de questions j'ai mal
je te jure j'ai ma dose
c'est bon lâche beaucoup j'ai ma dose le
massage est terminé s'il te plaît à
l'eau ok stop c'est bon ah mais c'est
moi qui va à des massages [ __ ] mais
j'aurais pu être là pendant deux jours
quoi sans déconner ce tutorial ton
premier massage ouais ouais ouais ouais
bon massage amma sa joie d'enfant gopal
je sois tu as fait masser par un enfant
mais bon quand j'étais enfant je passais
la même manière à les suivants du coup
j'ai trois étoiles et je peux rencontrer
peut-être oui marc tard c'est un match
non non mais à tout montrer mon corps à
mes attentes évoquant même s'ils
voulaient modélisme ça se fait partout
dans cette blague je m'accroche beaucoup
comme benoît c'est un rendez vous en
ligne de nombreux sketches aie aie tarn
est mignon non les bossus un peu gros
mais bon merci tu as un n'a en fait t'as
rien deux millions aussi bâtard sa et à
30 minutes t'as rien à voir avec un taux
de profit la voilà ça c'est vrai cette
photo de profil et un dessin c'est pas
une photo tu peux voir la différence
entre une fiction et la réalité est
évidemment je peux l'avoir et je peux
dire qu'avec toi je la vois mais c'est
un dessin de moi que de quand j'avais 19
ans quand j'étais mannequin pour une
marque de lingerie balata au moins tu es
au moins 60 ans pour avoir autant changé
moi ma celle du x 2 est là qui fait je
pense qu'il est qu'il fait bon ok elle
parle tout seul faire monory depuis tout
à l'heure et je gagne des points c'est
incroyable ça pouvait être comme ça avec
tous les humains ce serait cool je crois
que j'ai pas mal d'histoires de mes
années où j'étais modèle photo oui bah
je vois ça à prête à aller à paris on
m'a contacté pour que je sois le modèle
photo pour un burger
donc j'ai mis un bikini rouge et je vais
m'asseoir sur ce truc noir on arrête
tout on a tous je avec mes traductions
sera pas du tout je pense qu'on peut se
voir en vrai et on va beaucoup rire chez
sur quelle masse très bien plus on se
voit soir au quai du coup tu poses
plutôt comme un hamburger ou 15 ans
comme un modèle photo je sais pas lequel
de mass murder bassin peu c'est pareil
ah non ou là mais pas un truc bizarre
mon gars j'aime ce qu'elle va exploser
mais sa vie même pas juste ça tremble le
mec n'a pas de sens dans les bois ni
hasard parce que là je te fais c'est
légal en nous si tu marchais dessus avec
tes genoux en fait elle c'est bon j'en
ai assez j'en ai assez j'en ai assez vu
et c'était palpitant passionnant
émouvant halep 6 étoiles la suivant
c'est qui nicole 22 ans avec son chien
qui se prépare uriner y'a pas de soucis
alors johnny a rencontré nicole dans les
bois au milieu de la nuit
d'accord tu criais japan expo est johnny
jtag autant que tu sois là ça veut bout
ça représente beaucoup pour moi je sais
que c'était long de venir ici mais ça
valait le coup ok j'adore ton odeur
commence par t'éloigner mesures de
sécurité stade j'ai senti quelque chose
qui te rappellent un bon souvenir
ouais l'odeur du sang c'est vraiment le
lac le plus gai taux d'europe pour quand
je sens l'odeur du crayon ça me rappelle
mon enfance quand je rate ça me rappelle
mon breakfast ouais quand je sens des
pommes ça me rappelle ma mère moi le
crayon bassidji fois trop apparemment
c'était là le bon truc
nicole est parti en courant pour chasser
un écureuil dans le doute je vais
peut-être installé mythique et plus à
l'est sur linde genre ah c'est un
écureuil tout mignon je dois le suivait
à temps à la meuf elle sera elle songe à
tout seul je réponds même plus je gagne
quand même des points alors séparé qu'il
fait du bien c'est l'om qui se fait du
bien smart nicole est parti pour chasser
agro écureuils
c'est bien c'est bien mais fait ça fait
ça quand vous êtes au rendez vous il ya
pas de soucis partait chasser un truc
qui revenait mais en vidant la fille
sera plus là tu vas devoir payer
l'addition bon tu me massou pas avoir à
aller droit au but [ __ ] elle est
repartie un écureuil mais plus tard
basse moi et ça me langues regardez j'ai
un peu plus jamais canard voilà j'aime
pu devenir ce qu'elle dit je fais
non non j'espère les norns j'ai cliqué
sur une réponse vous y attendiez un
autre qui bouge et c'est dans mon
pantalon est là elle est partie mais
direct la queue entre les jambes
parce qu'elle a eu à moins que si vous
avez remarqué voilà allez vas-y masse
mois fait péter alors là on est sur
amazon wow ça bombarde à la fin je me
croyais dans un avion et des turbulences
[Musique]
j'attends de m'endormir
ok c'est bon c'est bon maintenant je me
casse des bois tu mas plus jamais d'une
douche plus jamais mais on passe à autre
chose alors alors est-ce qu'il y en a
une à dix étoiles on a dix étoiles des
étoiles c'est l ol ou johnny dans un
vaisseau spatial au milieu de nulle part
d'accord on passe on va sur sa attend
que j'espère c'est pas l'équivalent
féminin du mec de strip tease qui
fabrique sa soucoupe volante dans
l'espace pour croire que cet engin est
né du ciel comme ça il n'y change rien
bobby j ai pas fait de plan pour faire
store je rentre pas dedans sinon
réclamant haut et tu es tellement beau
faisons des bébés ici et maintenant non
white world jazz potes
allez c'est parti vas-y bon la rapide
efficace ma chère merci d'en compter
cinq sur cinq sur le ps store ce pas
dégueu c'est pas dégueulasse et des
petits à coup j'ai l'impression qu'elle
est en train de faire l'amour à mon cou
très bizarre car je voulais à poser
assez ingrat de le rendre compte vous
remercie pour ce massage c'était génial
alors dix étoiles maillot qui possède
dans ses cuillères de la mayonnaise
c'est un excellent jeu de mots je sens
que cette personne va me plaire au moa
maillot bienvenue dans mon appartement à
d'accord maillot c'était la mayonnaise
va cuire ce n'est pas la meuf super
drôle j'ai été très chanceuse qu'il y
ait un match au surligneur tu as de
belles fesses merci tu ne mettra jamais
une mayonnaise dessus je peux te le dire
mais c'est mais c'est une mayonnaise
mais quelque chose c'est dire de
mayonnaise j'arrête pas de faire georges
l'aiment bien et attend peut-être que la
maille obama c'est mieux que les autres
ok j'ai aussi dame jeanne et il vient
d'ouvrir le pot 2 et mass mois la
mayonnaise fais moi rêver la mayonnaise
blu ray qui fait eau
on dirait que tu fais le ces trucs avec
les malades comme ça c'est un truc que
je sais faire c'est exactement ça
sensations à temps il m'a soutenu que
les filles surtout ne change pas je vois
une photo de bonne mayonnaise match
direct c'est moins bruyant plus haut et
bas les amis c java de cette vidéo
s'il ya une utilité secondaire au jeu je
garder ça pour vous bref on oublie sa
roue mais ça n'était pas là elle aimait
la vie et vous ça vous a plu je suis
bouche bée je suis bouleversée je suis
tétanisé je vous conseille de tester
quoique le jeu coûte 5 euros en fait non
franchement tu mettes au téléphone un
vibreur tu le pose là tu t'appelles ait
à ligne fixe en boucle ces mêmes effets
en tout cas surtout de prochaine vidéo
merci de me regarder portez vous bien
lire tout le monde je retourne me faire
masser à bientôt
[Musique]